I remember uh
Louie's in the studio one night for like
a week we had already been in there for
a week and I went into the wrong uh
the studio
so we have been recording in like uh the
a room for like a week right this is
like the eighth ninth day in a row right
so whiz hit me like hey bro come uh come
pull up so we get to work so I pull up I
walk in the wrong Studio there's like
eight security guards outside that I
ain't never seen before so I'm like damn
who the homie must have somebody up in
here like you know I'm thinking he got
like
somebody you know what I'm saying so I
walk up in I say what's up to everybody
I I grew up in there man it's not weird
it's [ __ ] uh Playboy cardi oh [ __ ]
bro I'll walk up in that [ __ ] I'm like
oh
sh [ __ ] my bad like I apologize like but
we we've been in here for a week like
bro you know I'm not tripping so I'm
like hey bro I apologize bro I don't
mean to come interrupt interrupt your
session session I'm looking for cap so I
I bow to him bro like you feel me like I
I bow to this man as I leave the room
like as a as a show like respect yeah
about it to oh boy bam my bad bro and
get out your way
so I walked out out the room I'm walking
back across to the uh the parking lot to
uh uh uh go to the studio I'm like oh
I'm in the wrong ones let me let me go
over there
sounds like it costs a lot bro and like
I'm probably like 15 yards out I'm
pulling out my phone to call Cap like
hey bro like uh where you at yeah you
feel me
out of nowhere I hear hey [ __ ] I'm like
what the [ __ ] and I turn back it's
[ __ ] Playboy carty like running
outside bro in the blouse like you
running outside like
and then behind him is like six more
[ __ ] come out behind him and the door
opened again like six more [ __ ] behind
them bro so it's like 12.
13 [ __ ] outside when I look back and
in a matter of like two seconds bro what
they think you stole something or
something I'm trying to figure it out
I'm just I'm just doing the same [ __ ]
you doing I'm like bro what the [ __ ]
going on bro I I out of nowhere he's
like hey I don't like weird ass [ __ ]
coming up in my studio
I'm like whoa cause bro I'm I'm really
like taking her back like what the [ __ ]
is going on bro so I'm like hey bro
chill I'm like bro chill out like bro I
walked in now with some humble [ __ ] bro
and and I told you bro I was in the
wrong lab like bro you should be asking
your security guards why the [ __ ] they
let a random ass [ __ ] walk in there's
all six of them up and up in your
session they don't even know me from a
can of paint right that's who you should
be mad at he like oh oh
so so I'm like whoa I'm like [ __ ] what
are you doing bro I swear to Bro God
strike me down right now bro this [ __ ]
say on power sometimes I said look bro
we ain't gonna do all that extra that
[ __ ] because you know and I told him
where I was from you know what I'm
saying so I told him that he was like
what on piruto and I said oh uh oh no
you feel me I told him where I was from
I don't know I know so he like because
it's like oh uh he thought you like also
what's up then I'm like bro what you
trying to do I'm like I'm like bro I
squabble you and your whole Squad he
like oh I don't need no whole Squad I
scrub you all by myself I'm like oh this
[ __ ] turn I'm like bro he really crazy
like he don't see how this is a Playboy
cardi yes bro look I don't even know
this name from a can of paint I never
met this man before you feel me like we
ain't had no interactions so I'm really
like it's my first interaction with the
[ __ ] ever right so I'm like Boo
you know this what it is he told me
where he was from again
so that's when at the point where I'm
like bro what's up what you trying to do
he tell me
I scrub you all by myself I don't need
nobody so I'm like come on in let's go
bro come on I pull up like this you know
hold on we got my little chain huh yeah
I pulled up
pull my pants up are you from La you
know what that mean when [ __ ] I pulled
a pants up he was sitting back there
talking to his boys like that I said man
shut the [ __ ] up you ain't talking about
nothing I was low-key spooked though I
thought the [ __ ] about to whip my ass
on the way in as soon as I turned around
yeah I walked around the park and I said
shut the [ __ ] up walk back in a lot they
didn't say nothing
telling you bro well that makes
everything a lot more because right
before you got here Playboy Cardi's
artist was here and his Entourage was
here so you walked in and you were like
and then when they left you were like yo
Playboy cardi don't [ __ ] with me bro
that's why I'm not thinking it's gonna
get cracking I'm like bro like that's
what I'm trying to tell you bro this is
the last time I see him so after all
this
I walk in the studio I tell Wiz I'm like
hey bro this [ __ ] Playboy Carter you
crazy as [ __ ] bro you just read this I
ran up on you like 12 [ __ ] they just
low things
gonna go outside and Ninja Kick the [ __ ]
out these [ __ ] I'm like let's go [ __ ]
like I've been training already at this
point we'll start laughing he started
laughing he like ha he like he like that
sound like that crazy ass [ __ ] that's
my dog I'm like oh man I'm like man in
fact Playboy cardi was set on pyro no no
I told him look I'm trying to tell the
story but I don't know that's his boy so
he really like like laughing though he
like bro like that's my little bro like
like he like that he's like he crazy
like that I'm like oh he really liked
that I'm thinking he's just doing it for
a flex he's from Atlanta right I don't
know where he from that [ __ ] crazy
though apparently he's from Piru he can
he from pyro too but he can get the ones
wait wait car you can get the ones
believe that